Essam blue Loserville form a unique hip
european exceptional volum over a
parliament of a Ediciones shotta don't
renew reverse ave homie
DuBose akuti SAT exact Thomas okay -
Ezra continua de l'affaire accompany de
marsay for each a tool is automatically
a new service oovoo SI daca a we parkway
musician Baraka meses Ella democracy 11
June we easy occur the set democracy
European gentleman vote Suja to Inuvik
DEP DEP a lot it is a team with almost
almost as many women as men only one
woman away from gender balance this
shows
this shows we have made real progress
but also that we still have to do more
all together we will be one team that
works in the common European interest we
will be one team that works with this
house and with member states to tackle
our generations defining challenges we
are ready but most importantly Europe is
ready my message is simple let's get to
work
we can be the shapers of a better global
order this is Europe's vocation and it's
what European citizens want and I'm
happy to have such an experienced
diplomat as Joseph Burrell on our team
working alongside with yuta or pline
Aliyev our Halley and Yanni's lenarcik
they will do an invaluable job together
my commission will not be afraid to
speak the language of confidence but it
will be our way the European will way
this is the geopolitical commission that
I have in mind and that Europe urgently
needs we do not have a moment to waste
any more on fighting climate change
the faster Europe moves the greater the
advantage will be for our citizens our
competitiveness and our prosperity the
European Green Deal is a must for the
health of our planet and our people and
for our economy to him is looser
technology in Beheshti Londoner
opposites that's we heard militia had
quantum computer kunst agent elegans
blockchain on critter sure chip
technolog in the mid once toss a bug
linked the Madrid is a400m Lucas Incan
Muslim where does Susan and wind evolved
Eden immersed at such doubt sent either
less stones on Java source bundle owns a
gauge on the fashions capacitate
non-division Alfonso Joseph East Haddam
jet song done in deep axis we invest
less in innovation than our competitors
do this is a huge handicap to our
competitiveness and our ability to lead
this transformation this is why we
should not see the next multi-annual
financial framework as a simple
accounting exercise for those 39 people
for their mothers fathers and friends we
all agree that this should never ever
happen
people expect Europe to find common
solution to the share challenge of
migration this is an issue that has
divided us but we should step forward we
need solutions that work for all my
little sister died of cancer at the age
of eleven I remember the utter
helplessness of my parents but also of
the medical staff who looked after her
with such care every one of us has a
similar story I know someone who has the
number of cancer cases arising but we
are getting better at diagnosis and
treatment Europe will take the lead in
the fight against cancer early next year
Stella kiriakidis will launch an
ambitious cancer plan she's the right
person to make sure that Europe's
beating cancer plan helps to reduce the
suffering caused by this disease
[Applause]